it cost about 237 000 on average to
build a home in the united states and
the work typically takes three to six
months but crews in austin texas are
bringing 3d printing technology to home
construction they say they figured out a
way to build a house in less than two
days for a fraction of the cost oh my
omar villafranca looks at this new
approach
this just isn't a technology that's
going to help a little niche of the way
we think about children this is a
paradigm shift in the way we build
houses this technology starts with a
one-ton 3-d printer which squeezed out
enough concrete to build a small
two-bedroom one-bathroom single-family
home
jason ballard is co-founder of icon one
of the companies behind the project this
house right here was printed in 47 hours
at quarter speed at full speed could
have printed this house in 11 or 12
hours a home in 11 or 12 hours and
that's on version one of the technology
and it's designed to take families that
have been living in tents or shacks and
to bring them into what we believe is a
beautiful home that they can build their
lives on for the next few decades brett
hagler runs the non-profit news story
he's hoping to bring this technology to
poor communities in el salvador by the
end of next year when you see a home
like that
do you get excited about this i do i do
i'm excited about everything concrete
all right so you're going to add your
cement university of texas engineering
professor raza douglas farron is an
advisor on the project while she sees
the potential for 3-d printed homes she
questions how the concrete mix will
stand up over time is there enough data
out there saying that these kind of
homes can be safe no
there's not does not does the building
of these homes need to wait until
there's data or do the homes need to be
built and then study the data
you have to do them both at the same
time if we wait until there's data in
order to build it
you're never going to build it icon will
use this model home as an office for the
next few years while third-party labs
test its long-term durability we're
going to make ourselves the guinea pigs
before we put another family's life in
the mix and this particular design has
limitations utilities like electric and
plumbing still need to be installed
outside the walls right now it's just
going to be
a novelty it's just going to be
eye candy even if all goes as planned it
will likely be years before 3d printing
becomes a mainstay of u.s residential
construction
for cbs this morning omar villafranca
austin texas
that eye candy's pretty good afternoon i
love jason's jason's point that this is
just version one imagine what happens
when they really get it these 3d
printers are unbelievable all kinds of
surgical stuff they can do with them too
and i love one day you're gonna be able
to say i'm gonna just go edit the living
room yeah
that's true get the old adobe out and uh
you know that's something you got a new
addition that is coming for sure